hey I'm Kalani Hubbard and I'm a
filmmaker and I was asked by film
courage to make a little video about my
latest project and the camera gear that
I used to make that project so here we
go
so we created the six episode comedy
series called rocketship radio and the
comedy is just all about a struggling
rock band trying to make it in the world
and you know all the fun challenges
along the way when me and my friend
started writing this series and we were
talking about you know what camera
should we use and you know how are we
gonna pull this off and we ended up
choosing the Canon c100 to make this
project so this project was super
run-and-gun
and super low budget and we had one week
to film everything and we didn't really
have a lot of options we wanted to rent
a red scarlet but because a red scarlet
costs more than our entire project costs
that didn't really seem like a good idea
the main reason we shot what the Canon
c100 was because I already owned a c100
and I actually had two other friends
that owned to see one hundred so it kind
of made the most sense for us to call in
a few favors get some cameras from
friends and just shoot this thing as
quickly and as low-budget as we possibly
could so we could use our budget on
other things like feeding the crew and
you know having some locations even
though the Canon c100 wasn't necessarily
my first choice I'd ended up being a
really great camera for the situations
we were in because everything was so
run-and-gun
the great thing about the Canon c100 is
that it's a really fast camera you can
turn it on and you can start recording
in seconds which is really great when
you're just trying to capture a moment
another thing is that the battery lasts
a really long time so we would have
these extra big batteries that we put in
them and they would last an entire
production day another great thing is
that the cards seemed to never fill up
the little mts files are so small but
the quality is actually really good so
we ended up writing a scene about a cat
cafe where all the characters meet in
this cat cafe and they have coffee and
hang out and that's their kind of
meeting spot and that there was six
episodes so within that each episode had
a cat cafe scene so this was a large
location as far as script and story goes
and we had the location for four hours
which was pretty insane for us to shoot
six different episodes with multiple
scenes in four hours in one location
but because I had two other friends that
onc one hundreds we ended up throwing
those cameras on tripods and literally
blasting out all these scenes in one to
two takes and in post we were able to
cut to all these different camera angles
and really make these scenes work out
that's another great thing about the
c100 is that they're a lot more
accessible and they're a lot easier to
get your hands on and they're a lot
cheaper to rent overall I think we
really achieved it look we were going
for for this series and the c100 really
pulled it off we weren't really going
for super cinematic or really serious
it's a lightweight comedy you know so we
wanted a camera on sticks or we wanted
to camera on a shoulder mount and you
know witty conversations and this and
that and I think this camera really did
pull it off and I'm really happy with it
and most of all we fit within our budget
so you're telling me we make no money um
yeah I ended up owning a read after I
filmed rocketship radio show and I don't
take fact the fact that I shot it on
Canon c100 s because I learned so much
from creating this and now that I own a
read I'm going to take what I learned
from that project and apply it to the
next I'm really glad that not having the
exact camera gear that we wanted didn't
stop us from creating the project that
we wanted to create and I just want to
encourage you guys that you know if you
don't have the exact camera that you
wish you had or you know it's not the
latest and greatest thing don't worry
about that just go out and make
something the best that you can with the
camera that you have so thank you guys
so much for watching this video if you
want to know more about the series I've
been talking about that we shot all into
one hundreds you can find it at
rocketship radio show calm until next
time see you guys later